The number that you would fill in, in these boxes, is negative 1 3rd. So,
instead of thinking of dividing each side by negative 3, you could instead think
about multiplying each side by negative 1 3rd. Multiplying by negative 1 3rd is
actually pretty much exactly the same as dividing by negative 3. The reason for
this is because of fraction multiplication, and its relationship to division.
So, if we have negative 3 time negative 1 3rd, we convert negative 3 to a
fraction of negative 3 over 1. Then, if we just do some fraction multiplication,
so you mutiply the top by the top and the bottom by the bottom, we end up with
negative 3 times negative 1, or positive 3 over 1 times 3, which is just
positive 3 again. And 3 over 3 is just 1. So, multiplying by fractions is just a
different way to think about doing division. I want you to decide which way
works better for you. Thinking of dividing this side by the coefficient that's
in front of x, or multiplying by its reciprocal. Either way is completely fine.